[Music]
all right and welcome back to
politically incorrect my guests are our
city hall and Bobcat golf ratings isn't
it great to be back in 1997 the young
comedians yeah you're Dorian Gray
painting you know back in the day my
line on Rodney King was if you ever see
me getting beaten by the police put the
video camera down and help me bring in
the new millennium
but you have kids right yes yes you have
a kid you know somebody I know who as a
kid said you know now that I have a kid
if a guy was driving a hundred miles an
hour through my neighborhood I would
want the police to wail on him Wow well
I mean kids changer yeah well if I
didn't like my kids I'm just saying
that's what somebody says I just thought
that was interesting from the person
people with child perspective I remember
the first time I saw the video I was
like that brother must have done
something you know because they were
whipping his ass so vehemently you know
it was like what you know I couldn't
believe that he hadn't done anything
well he did drive through a name he was
going fast
yes he was going fast I agree I agree
that that's not justified hazing amazed
you had some involvement without it did
your not it was it was very interesting
from my perspective learning at the foot
of a black man about black people a foul
yeah especially about the history of
black people in our country which is not
a sterling history and have this happen
and to have George Herbert Walker Bush
then the president of course turned to
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Powell and say we need to
do something we need to federalize the
guard out in California and we need to
do something we need to restore order
and so forth in college wait a minute
wait a minute let me mr. president give
you some facts and they had a really
good discussion and Bush stood down oh
that was the old Republican Party that
was the older brother listen to facts
[Laughter]
it's a quaint notion I mean I'm a huge
I'm a huge fan of : Powell what did you
learn from him about black people in
their history that you didn't know
already I learned that I had such a void
in my historical knowledge of this
country from its colonial period to the
World War two period dead I was ignorant
and he put me in the books and he put me
with the people I interviewed over 750
World War 2 veterans and I kept asking
them over and over again why why why
would you come back to a country that
treats you like it does why did you
fight for this country and I got the
same answer every time it's my country
too and one day it might live up to its
its beliefs
okay
here's a question for you from a mr.
ghost what advice would you give a
potential candidate who confides he has
had an extramarital affair don't admit
to it actually just whatever you do
don't lie about if you get caught and
you you've got to fess up that's the
first thing first and foremost because
they'll always find out if you were John
Edwards what you efest up at what point
I mean he had so many opportunities but
yeah he should have once he got caught
yeah you come up someone's always gonna
talk I promise you there's always
someone who's going to talk you know
what we don't have very much
conversation in this country about what
a great family man we have in the Oval
Office right now Barack Obama there's
there's no honky tonk there's there's no
side stories there there's no garbage
there's no crap I mean he's because he
has to be the Jackie Robinson of
politics as I always say because if he
makes one wrong move they this
experiment with the black president we
were talking about is over if there had
been a shaquita someplace on the south
side of Chicago
but do you really think that the people
that President Obama motivated back in
2008 I mean the the youth vote came out
I think a lot of young people didn't see
color when they voted for President
Obama I think there were people that did
but the the group that he motivated and
this is why the Democrats got behind him
instead of Hillary seriously because he
could bring in a whole new generation of
young people and get him into the
political process where they thought
demographically Hillary really couldn't
do that and that's the publican party is
that they're not embracing change and
they're not getting younger people in
that can that are much more aware and
the wealthy you don't want anybody you
don't want women you don't want the
young people you know what I mean yet
conversely I mean Sarah Palin famously
at the convention had a pregnant
daughter yeah you know where I guess she
was she fresh she lost she had the baby
Newt Gingrich I know she the girl girl
was with child
yes okay we cannot really you know in
the barber shop just let you know that
Sarah's baby bro you know yes that's
gotta keep no iron keep you in touch
with the barber shop but conversely can
we really even in America picture if
Barack Obama had this similar situation
if his daughter was bright I mean if I
mean it just is inconceivable that
America would accept that as they did
with Sarah Palin so that's so much for
your post-racial America right yeah
absolutely actually Obama said the kids
were off-limits yeah you know I mean so
just used to seeing hillbillies pregnant
it's not that
that's right exactly it's one of the
reasons I wasn't gonna vote for Jessie
because I didn't want a first lady in
the first babies mama in the White House
you know what he was going through at
that time right exact so Obama I'm
incredibly proud of his past his present
and I'm looking forward to his future I
am okay
Colonel Wilkinson are you concerned with
neoconservatives resurgence in the
Republican Party and the calls to attack
Iran absolutely absolutely I see some of
the same people making some of the same
statements they're even reading off the
same sheet of music John Bolton and
others this is another war in Western
Asia for the United States would be
catastrophic and the president very
bravely courageously defying people like
John McCain and Lindsey Graham and other
stalwarts of my party has started down a
negotiating track that has every reason
to succeed if people just let him do it
it's funny that in a way the Obama
method is sort of the opposite of the
Powell doctrine which was overwhelming
force decisive force okay but Obama
seems to use the least amount like to
get Libya yet Qaddafi a billion dollars
as opposed to a trillion to get Saddam
Hussein the Somali pirates Newt Gingrich
said let's invade now couple of snipers
took him out drones you know they've
been Laden raid he seems to do what Mitt
Romney loves in business be super
efficient I won't dispute that but I
will say that that's a dangerous road to
walk down if you're not closing the door
and what I mean by that is Libya is
still a huge question Afghanistan is
still a huge question Iraq is still a
huge question right now Syria is blowing
up and Maliki on the one hand is funding
one side of Syria moqtada al-sadr is
funding another side of Syria's this
kind of delicate Democrat gradual
response walking into Vietnam it's not
necessarily the best I stick with Powell
gosh back in the 90s fellas blowing up
and get
popular right absolutely all right we're
gonna go enjoy a reminiscence backstage
yeah this is this is over that's yeah
we're way over we're just having it too
good at the time yeah thank you
everybody will see you next Real Time
with Bill Maher ask Bill and his guest
your questions right after the show at
hbo.com